did I say we're gonna do we're gonna
take this basic guy and then we're going
to transform it right now I'm gonna take
this opportunity to go back to
yesterday's lesson and come all the way
back and I realized that part of what I
was trying to do was hard because I was
doing some freehand so this graph here
um it is actually even though you didn't
see it in this form yesterday it is in
the notes accessible on canvas so go
ahead and look at that up if you want to
see this in more detail what's going on
here and we know how to translate ins
work we slide those things around and
then when it comes to dilation what
we're thinking about is taking the graph
and then sort of stretching it along the
x direction or the Y direction or both
right so this is the example of
stretching a parabola in the X direction
and I hope you can see every single
point on the graph you could take any
spot like say let's have a look down
here if you have a look at the x
intercept it was one and I stretched
this parabola so it was double it was
twice as far away so that x intercept
which used to be one now it's two if I
look at a spot like this what's that
looking at my scale that's zero point
six so when I stretch it out double you
can see it's stretched out all the way
to over here which is one point two if
you look at that scale right so this is
the horizontal dilation that we looked
at before this is a vertical dilation
right this time I chose a different
value to stretch by it you can see on
the left hand side I'm stretching by a
factor of three so therefore you should
expect everything to not be double this
far away it's gonna be triple as far
away three times as far right so if you
have a look at a spot like say over
let's see over here on the left hand
side right um this first set of
coordinates here that I've found the Y
value looks like one if you have a look
at the scale there and when I stretch it
out the new Y value all the way up here
that's a Y value of three that you can
see it corresponds to okay so we're
gonna take this knowledge and we're
going to apply it translation and
dilation to our absolute value graphs
down here so let's have a go this guy
first when you see this equation y
equals the absolute value of x plus
three I want you to think about what
that plus three which is the only
difference what is it doing
and what
effect is it going to have visually so
the first question is that plus three
what is it attached to have a look
closely and you can see it's um it's
adjusting the X right like the way I
visualize this is a bit like if you've
ever watched Formula One racing and
you've got the the car pulls into the
pit stop and then suddenly all these
people jump in and then they start
working on different tires so you have a
think about where is that person
attached and what are they changing
which part of the car they adjusting and
which part of this equation or this
function is being amended or transformed
here and the answer is this plus three
it's clearly attached to the X so I'm
going to get a translation along the x
axis its horizontal right I'm gonna take
that blue graph over on the left hand
side and I'm gonna think about which way
it's going to go which direction does it
going can you point actually in your
classroom which way is the graph going
to go this is really funny because
you're like I'm pointing in that
direction but it's reversed because it's
reflected across this camera and to be
confusing okay so it's a plus three
right so the axis is going to move plus
three which means the graph is going to
go in the leftward direction right so
I'm not sure if that looks correct to
you leftward direction anyway okay so
I'm gonna have instead of an intercept
at the origin over here at X equal zero
I'm gonna have one at x equals negative
three and then everything else is the
same so this same kind of v-shape this
rebounding thing is gonna happen all
over again so I have this and I've got
this okay now before we leave off right
you can see there's more information
that I need to put on to this graph now
that I've done the translation the x
intercept came from our knowledge of
which way the graph was moving but you
can see I have a new y intercept now
right I can go through the origin
anymore so hopefully you can see from
the symmetry of the graph I'm gonna get
a y-intercept of three okay now last
piece of information earlier you saw I
took this algebraic definition and I
said hey you've got the left sorry the
right part of the graph the right branch
and then you've got the left branch and
they have completely different equations
well what will the equations be for the
branches
of this line have a think about this
carefully for a second right part of its
easy part of its hard right part of this
graph is just going to be the absolute
value of x plus three will just be X
plus three which part of the graph is at
which branch is it it's gonna be though
can you point out it will I be able to
work out if you point at the screen
which part of the screen you're pointing
at oh it's going to be the right-hand
part of the graph right because there's
a positive gradient there so I want you
to go ahead and label that right-hand
side as y equals x plus 3 now what about
the other part well if we go back to our
definition of the absolute value our
algebraic one right when you have a
negative value there when X plus three
is negative so when X plus 3 is less
than 0 the graph Y will be equal to
minus everything inside the brackets
everything inside the brackets right so
that's the X and the plus 3 so if I
expand my brackets there you're gonna
get let me slide up a little bit minus X
minus 3 right and hopefully these both
make sense to us think about the domain
restriction in the first section here X
plus 3 is less than 0 if I made X the
subject there I'd say X is less than
negative 3 up subtract 3 from both sides
well that makes sense right
have a look at the graph up above you
can see right here it's it's a straight
line and then when does it switch over
and the answer is right there at the
intercept when X is negative less than
negative 3 that's when I'm behaving like
this and then at negative 3 I switch
over okay
and then secondly if you have a look at
this equation here y equals minus X
minus 3 the gradient is negative 1 and
of course if I continued that graph
let's go into green here if I continue
downward you can see I would have
collided here with the y axis at
negative 3 so this is you know y equals
MX plus B that's the y intercept that I
would have gotten but of course it has
rebounded up above to this positive
value up here ok all right so we've done
a horizontal translation I'm gonna ask
you guys and teachers in the room I'd
love if you hadn't wander around and
check how people go in this if that's
what a horizontal translation looks like
what is this going to mean
okay now you can see here that I've
written this equation a little bit
differently and it's where our algebraic
definition is really gonna help and our
intuitive definition we have to be very
cautious with so I'm gonna let you have
a go I'll give you a couple minutes to
see how you fare graphing this guy on
the right hand side
it teaches if no students in the room
are getting is really rapidly or you
know don't have any trouble at all
please wave at me and give me the signal
to continue otherwise I'd love you to
have a shot in it see what you come up
with and then I'll show you my solution
in a couple minutes okay off you go come
back together shortly let's have a go at
this now you can see what I've done is
I've drawn myself some I like to call
them guide lines not guidelines but
lines that are going to guide this new
graph that I'm going to draw okay so the
basic graph y equals absolute value of X
is always kind of in my head I've kind
of gotten to the point where I've
graphed this enough then I'm like I know
what that looks like and I can do the
transformations straight away but I kind
of want to pull back the curtains of my
brain as it were so you can see my
thinking process okay now this is not a
horizontal translation that like we
looked at before this is going to be a
vertical translation and you can see
that more obviously more clearly if you
take that minus 2 if you add it to both
sides so I'm going to add 2 to both
sides you can see the 2 is really like
again go back to that forming the 1
metaphor I gave you right where is that
plus 2 working what's it actually acting
upon and the answer is it's acting on Y
it's not inside the absolute value
acting on X it's changing around your
vertical values all of your Y values
okay so that plus 2 means the axis is
going to move upward relative to the
graph which means the graph is actually
going to move downwards so that's why I
hope your graph looks something like
this
ok you can see I've got this sort of
relative movement here everything is
sort of shifted downwards okay now
clearly I need to put on some more
information I've got count on 3
intercepts that I need to put on there
and because I've given you some fairly
easy values I hope you can just
basically read them off for starters I
used to have my one-and-only intercept
at the origin it's moved down two units
so it's at negative two because your
gradients one that means you can quickly
read off that that's two and
- as well and you're good to go at this
point though it's worth mentioning like
I said before we should label our
branches
I was actually bit cheeky I didn't we
worked it out but I didn't label them
last time and we had y equals x plus 3
and y equals minus X minus 3
what will the branches look like here
I'm gonna get my guidelines out of the
way because now they're just obstructing
my work let me just delete those okay
what's the right-hand one going to be it
generally is the easier one because the
absolute value of a positive number it's
just a positive number
this guy here is just going to be
absolute value of X becomes X so it's X
minus 2 what happens on the left hand
side well because the absolute value
didn't apply to the two it's going to
stay a minus two right it's going to be
minus X minus 2 now you can actually you
can sort of slightly get away with just
labeling the whole thing with a single
equation you're just saying it's the
absolute value of X minus 2 as a whole
thing and just leave it there but I
think you should get in the habit it's a
helpful thing and an assist your and
geometric thinking to label each of the
branches independently ok